allowing Republican Congressman George
Santos was met with some brutal heckling
brutal heckling at LaGuardia Airport
when he arrived yesterday he faced
questions continuing to face questions
about more of his lies now it turns out
that he appears to have
um you know I I don't know the right
terminology I don't know if he was a
drag queen like I don't know dressed in
drag was a drag queen I don't know what
I do know
is that Republicans for a year have been
saying that drag queens are one of the
greatest threats to America and our
children that they have ever seen from
the left and it turns out George Santos
appears to have also dressed in drag he
seems to be admitting it he's just
saying I was having fun okay we'll get
to that on the bonus show anyway he
arrives at LaGuardia Airport
and is immediately swarmed take a look
at this
you've already told you specifically in
DC that I would sit with you okay if you
approached it throughout the proper
Channel
call my office oh I did they don't write
back to me
look at this
case for you guys
yes
look at all the work he's doing
congressman who did you speak with
classified classified
that's genius so I I looked into that
um my understanding is that who he meets
with is not classified it's just private
you know and and this is again these
people have no business in these roles
it's classified no you might just not
give us the names of everyone you met
with although it might actually be
public record I don't know
um look guys I wish you guys were all
I'm gonna go in the elevator I wish you
guys well
so there he is asked about the drag
queen stuff he says I was young and I
had fun assuming for having a life
was your mother at the World Trade
Center on 911 is related to the fact
that Santos has told two different
stories about when his mother died I
love your guy who keeps following me
good job tipping you guys
offer two days
all right so then he gets himself into
an elevator here's a nice one cbs2
talked about this they are now as a
matter of fact just introducing him as a
disgraced Congressman which I have to
tell you I love we begin with breaking
news tonight disgraced Congressman
George Santos he's been he's been in
office a week and they're already
referring to him as disgraced
Congressman back in town our cameras
were there when he landed at LaGuardia
late this afternoon yeah
as you heard in the background there's
someone yelled con artists
claim he ignored many of the questions
from reporters but did say he's working
for his constituents he also criticized
the media I wish you guys well I'm gonna
go and I have spoken with the voters
I've been in District the whole week
I've been taking constituent calls I've
received Federal grant applications for
projects in the district and I look
forward to serving the people the one
thing I'll say is the media and we've
received plenty of complaints about you
guys staking up the embattled lawmaker
is facing more scrutiny over his past
Santos said his mother escaped the south
tower on 9 11 but a researcher obtained
immigration records showing she was in
Brazil at the time yeah anyway
um we are going to have to stay on this
because I I really do fear fear and I'm
increasingly thinking that he is just
going to stick it out no matter how
humiliating it is he wants to be a big
boy congressman and he is going to just
try to avoid the pressure on him to
resign for now and he may well get away
with it because I'll be honest I don't
know how long like eventually
I think eventually we'll get to the end
of his lies that can be uncovered and so
then it's just recycling stories and
saying we still think he should resign
the story will go away so let us keep
the pressure on media outlets and other
members of Congress to keep the pressure
on Santos but I'm worried that this may
be starting to lose Steam and he may be
able to end up serving those two years
which would be absolutely horrible one
of our sponsors is paired the app for
couples every day paired gives you and
your partner questions quizzes games to
have fun to stay connected to deepen
your conversations and get to know each
other better what's great about it is
you don't even have to be in the same
room especially with the baby right now
my girlfriend and I are quite busy and
paired really helped us to stay
connected you get a daily question to
answer you can't see your partner's
answer until you answer yourself and
their questions about everything
relationship life intimacy other things
and all of the exercises were developed
by academic psychologists and expert
relationship therapists as well
questions like what makes you feel lucky
in your relationship great when you want
to remember and have gratitude a really
great thing what's an activity you could
try together this month actually gets
people thinking about things to do it
can go in really funny directions as
well but it just always feels like time
well spent head over to paired.com
Pacman for a seven day free trial and 25
off a subscription the link is down
below